[موسيقى]
يعود من جديد ويعلن استعداده لتعبئه
الجيوش من اجل موسكو
ويواصل الهجوم على موسكو فما الذي يريده
وبولندا تتحضر للحرب وتنشر القناصه على
الحدود لندن تدمر عشرات الدبابات وترفض
تسليمها لاوكرانيا
من بيلاروسيا ولكن بشروط والمكسيك تنضم
للسعوديه في وساطه الازمه الاوكرانيه
والكرملين يرحب الموساد الاسرائيلي يتحرك
سرا من اجل السعوديه والرياض تلعبها بذكاء
هذه المره و واشنطن تعلن عن مفتاحها
لمواجهه الصين عسكريا في المحيط الهادئ
ومتحديا اكثر من مليار مسلم سلوان موميكا
يقدم على حرق القران مجددا
بوتين يضرب وزيلنسكي يصرخ
المعارف يحتد لهيبها والخسائر الاوكرانيه
تتضاعف والدعم الغربي لا يوقف نزيف
الاراضي في اوكرانيا ليعلن وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو ان القوات الاوكرانيه
فقدت خلال الشهر الماضي خلال المعارك نحو
21 الف جندي واكثر من 2000 قطعه من
الاليات العسكريه فعن اي ارقام نتحدث وها
هو المصدر هو من يتحدث امامكم قال وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو ان القوات
الاوكرانيه فقدت في الشهر الحالي خلال
المعارك نحو 21 الف جندي واكثر من 2000
قطعه من الاليات العسكريه لتمضك ايديها
نحو الولايات المتحده طالبه النجده حيث
قال مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي
ان كييف ستبدا مشاوره مع واشنطن هذا
الاسبوع بشان تقديم ضمانات امنيه لها
ريثما تكتمل عمليه الانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي يبدو ان صبر الاوكرانيين بدا ينفذ
يا ساده وخزان المقاومه لم يعد به الكثير
اذا لما لا تتجه كياف نحو المبادره
السعوديه وهنا يعلن الرئيس المكسيكي
ان بلاده مستعده للمشاركه في مفاوضات
السلام في اوكرانيا التي تنظمها السعوديه
في حال مشاركه طرفي النزاع فيها فقط موسكو
اعلنت انها ستراقب عن كتب الاجتماع عقده
في السعوديه بشان اوكرانيا فهل تقبل كياف
ببساطه السعوديه والمكسيكي ومعهما نحو 30
دوله الوضع مئات للحوار يا هؤلاء حتى
بريطانيا احد اكبر الدعمين لاوكرانيا غيرت
نهجها وقامت بتدمير 43 دبابه من طراز
تشالنجر 2 كان من الممكن نقلها الى كييف
لكن لندن ابت الا ان تتلف تلك الدبابات
وفق صحيفه التايمز كييف ما زالت تتعنت
وتميل الى مواصله الحرب عوضا عن التهدئه
حيث قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي مرزيلنسكي
ان الحرب تصل روسيا ومراكزها الرمزيه وذلك
بعد يومين من هجوم بطائرات مسيره استهدف
موسكو وادى الى وقف حركه الملاحه في احد
مطاراتها الدوليه لفتره
من رئيس الاوكراني من ان الحرب تعود على
ارض روسيا تدريجيا وتطالب مراكزها الرمزيه
وقواعدها العسكريه وهذا مسار لا مفر منه
طبيعي وعادل بلا ريب بحسب قوله لننتقل الى
ميدان المعارك حيث اعلنت سلطات جمهوريه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت اراضي الجمهوريه
75 مره خلال 24 ساعه واطلقت 275 قذيفه
مختلفه وعلى ذات السياق اعلن وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان قواته تحقق نجاحا بالقرب من
بخماط في مجله القوات الروسيه هجوما مكثفا
في خراكياف حيث قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الطائره الاوكرانيه شنت
غارات على مناطق تمركز القوات الروسيه في
ديمبرو وخيراسون واسقطت الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اربع مسيرات واربع طائرات
استطلاع بدون طيار لترد موسكو على لسان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه والتي اعلنت ان
قواتها عده هجمات وقضت على نحو 710 جنود
اوكرانيين على مختلف المحاور خلال يوم كما
اسقطت الطائره 25 اوكرانيه اضافه
الى فاكرين مسيره يا لها من اعداد كبيره
والعهده على المصدر وهو الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه ومن المعارك الاوكرانيه
الى الحرب التي تطبخ على نار هادئه عن
بولندا نتحدث وبعد ان كانت قد عززت وارسو
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا بسبب وجود مقاتل
مجموعه فاجنار هناك اعلنت قياده القوات
المسلحه الفولانديه في تغريده على تويتر
انها قامت بنشر مجموعه من القناصه على
الحدود مع بيلاروس البولنديون يعلمون بان
فاجنار لا تلعب سمكه تندلع الحرب بعد كل
هذه التوترات كانت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه قد قالت ان الاف من جنود
فاقنار مستقرون في معسكر في منطقه تسيل
وسط بيلاروسيا منذ منتصف يوليو واضافت
الوزاره انه تم رصد حوالي 300 خيمه و200
مركبه في الموقع المذكور مشيره الى ان صور
الاقمار الصناعيه تظهر وصول مئات الم الى
المعسكر فما الذي تخططونه فاجنار ليجيب
قائد مجموعه فاقنار الروسيه
ملمحا الى امكانيه اتخاذ قرار بتجنيد
مقاتلنا جدد اذا احتجت روسيا ذلك ومؤكدا
ان العمل مستمر في مراكز التدريب في
بيلاروسيا اعاد حديثه مره اخرى عن استعداد
مقاتله لرحله جديده في افريقيا فهل يضر
الرماد على عيون بولندا وليتوانيا ثم ينقض
على حدودهما وفي السياق البيلاروسي اكد
الكسندر بوليشوك مدير الدائره الثانيه
لبلدان رابطه الدول المستقله بالخارجيه
الروسيه في تصريحات لوكاله انه لا يمكن
الحديث عن سحب الاسلحه النوويه التكليكيه
الروسيه من بيلاروسيا الا بعد التخلي
واشنطن وحلفائها عن نهجهم المدمر وسحب
الاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه من اوروبا
وبعيدا عن النووي ينتقل الروس نحو سلاح
اخر انه سلاح الطاقه حيث قال
ان مقترح اقامه مركز للغاز في تركيا لا
يزال مطروحا وان موسكو تريد انشاء منصه
الكترونيه لمبيعات الغاز هناك
الاحداث والتطورات كشفت مصادر امريكيه
لموقع اوكسيوس ان رئيس جهاز الاسرائيلي
زارا واشنطن سرا قبل نحو اسبوعين لاجراء
محادثات مع كبار المسؤولين حول اتفاق
التطبيع مع السعودي ياتي هذا بينما يخشى
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون من ان يوافق رئيس
الوزراء على طلب سعودي باقامه محطه نوويه
مقابل التطبيع مع تل ابيب وهناك يزداد قلق
اسرائيل من ان تستغل الرياض الاتفاقيه
لاغراض عسكريه بحسب صحيفه يوضعت ارحانوت
العبريه وفقا لوكاله فرانسبريس فان
الميتشر جنرال جوزيف رايان قائد فرقه
المشاه 25 والتي يتكون قوامها من 12000
جنديا في اوا
واضحه للغايه في المنطقه مضيفا ان
الولايات المتحده ستعتمد على الحلفاء بدلا
من التوسع الكبير لقواتها لمواجهه اي خطر
عسكري صيني في المحيط الهادئ اعلنت الشرطه
الباكستانيه ان عدد قتل التفجير الانتحاري
الذي وقع في تجمع سياسي بمنطقه باجوت
ارتفع الى 54 مع اصابه ما يقرب من 200 شخص
وقالت الشرطه ان تحقيقاتها الاوليه تشير
الى ان الفرع الاقليمي لتنظيم داعش ربما
يكون وراء الهجوم المجلس العسكري وفي
النيجر يتهم فرنسا بالتخطيط للتدخل عسكريا
لتحرير الرئيس بازار وموسكو تدعو لضبط
النفس والعوده الى الشرعيه
سيلوان موميكا يقدم على حرق القران مجددا
امام البرلمان السويدي متحديا بذلك اكثر
من مليار مسلم بينما اعرب وزير الخارجيه
الدنماركي لارس لوكا راس موسون عن امله في
ان يسهم مقترح حكومه بلاده للحد من حوادث
حرق المصحف في تهدئه تصعيد دوليا متزايد
مع دول مسلمه عده بينما بعثت السويد بخطاب
ل75 دوله اما السعوديه قبله المسلمين فقد
اكتفت بالتنديد على خجل
[موسيقى]